mise en place aujourd'hui à paris de la
commission informatique et libertés
cette commission créée il ya deux ans a
pour tâche la surveillance de nos
libertés
comment va-t-elle s'y retrouver dans les
quelques 125 me différents fichiers sur
ordinateur réponse de georges le père un
téléphone un simple téléphone votre
téléphone peut un jour si vous n'y
prenez pas garde vous menacé par exemple
quand vous passez une commande dans un
centre de vente par correspondance
l'ordinateur qui enregistre votre
commande constitue un fichier une liste
de noms dont le vôtre si on rassemble
plusieurs de vos commandes on peut
découvrir outre votre nom adresse
téléphone une idée de vos goûts de vos
revenus de l'emploi que vous en faites
et bien d'autres choses en termes de
métiers ont dit que différents fichiers
ont été mises ensemble des ordinateurs
ont été internés cté et différentes
informations vous concernant vos
maladies vous impose aux amandes rami
que sais-je se retrouvent sur la même
fiche celui qui peut consultez cette
fiche a du coup un énorme le pouvoir sur
vous c'est contre cela que la commission
informatique et libertés a été constitué
après le recensement de ces 125 1000
fichiers et la vérification de leur
interconnexion possible elle aura
l'énorme travail de défendre le citoyen
contre les aspects négatifs de
l'utilisation de l'ordinateur
le particulier connaissant l'existence
d'un fichier le concernant demandera ou
à l'administration publique
il s'agit d'un fichier du secteur public
ou bien entreprises privées s'il s'agit
du secteur privé demandera communication
de la connaissance de la fiche ou des
fiches qui le concerne il aura ce qu'on
appelle un droit d'accès à cette fiche
et si le particulier estime que les
informations qui sont contenus dans
cette fiche sont de nature à lui nuire
et bien il demandera ou à
l'administration ou à l'établissement [ __ ]
de procéder à des rectifications et en
cas de difficulté de refus par exemple
de l'administration ou de l'entreprise
privée et saisira notre commission qui
tranchera la question
il existe un certain nombre de limites
légales notamment lorsqu'il s'agit de
sûreté de l'état de défense nationale de
sécurité publique on peut demander sa
fiche de défense nationale par exemple
on peut demander sa fiche si la
déclaration qui a été faite à la
commission le prévoit au cas contraire
il est impossible effectivement d'avoir
accès à des fichiers qui touche à la
défense nationale
vous avez donc un pouvoir un peu limité
dans ce domaine là non je crois que le
pouvoir est extrêmement vaste et que les
fichiers qui concerne la défense
nationale la sûreté de l'état ou la
sécurité publique je l'espère en tous
les cas ce rang le moins nombreux
possible mais les possibilités qui sont
donnés à la commission et donc aux
citoyens sont des possibilités
extrêmement large puisque la commission
est une atteinte organisme totalement
indépendant de tous les pouvoirs